In today's video,
we are going to find out just
how much paint is actually
in a spray paint can,
mix some colors together,
and then try boiling it.
[Music]
We have a little bit
of leftover spray paint
from a couple of projects.
Just a few.
Just just a little.
We might have an addiction
to spray for you.
I've always been curious to see
a few things about spray paint.
For one,
how much paint do you actually
get out of one of these cans?
I also want to see
what spray paint looks like
when it's just sitting in a pot,
like a gallon of it.
Most people know
that you could spray
spray paint into a fire,
and it'll burn, it'll catch.
However, a lot of that
is the propellant itself,
and not necessarily the paint.
Finally, we want
to see what happens
if we add a little bit of heat.
Does it boil?
Does it just burn?
We don't know, and we want to.
Here's the basic idea.
We have got a lot
of spray paint.
We're going to try spraying
it all into one pot,
and then turn on the heat.
Let's see how much
spray paint is in a pot.
Although, one other thing,
we are in a dome,
and it's pretty big,
but we have a lot
of spray paint.
I think we sprayed
it all in here,
we would end up high as a kite.
So we're going to take the pot
and the spray paint outside,
and do the spraying there.
Supposedly, there's
15 ounces in this can.
Time to find out.
[Music]
It's pretty color.
This may take longer
than I thought.
[Music]
Thanks.
So much better.
This is wonderful.
You're so helpful.
I mean, the fumes
aren't going on you.
That's-- That's fair.
But you're kind of cold.
But this is not 15 ounces
worth of paint.
Yeah, I think you're right.
I think we just lost
a ton of it to the air.
Yeah.
I feel like when
I'm painting things,
I run out of spray paint
faster than this.
I know.
When you're, when you're trying
to paint with it,
you get like three passes,
and then you're like,
the can ran out.
This can never come ahead.
Now, to be clear,
this was a brand
new can of paint.
Most of these will be half used,
but we wanted to see exactly
how much was in a brand-new can,
and shockingly, it's a lot.
Speaking of which--
Is that it?
It's pretty much there.
That's a whole can
of spray paint.
That's sad.
That looks really cool though.
It's beautiful, but there's
not much in here.
That's very cold.
So we were looking at the can,
or not the can, we're looking
at the bottom of the pot,
and it's actually--
It's frozen over.
Yeah.
This much paint depressurizing
actually comes out very cold,
and it's cold out here anyway,
so it just sort of stays cold
once it gets cold.
Look at that.
The bottom of the pot
has frosted over,
and Calli stuck her finger
into the paint, and said
that it's also very cold.
Let's do more.
More colors.
[Music]
That's about a gallon
of spray paint right there.
That's amazing.
So much.
With hydro-dipping,
you have paint on top of water.
Here, we've just got
paint on top of more paint.
So it's not going
to work nearly the same,
or probably nearly
as successful but--
I suspect this whole thing--
We're going to--
We've got this clear Christmas
ornament, and I suspect
that the whole thing will just
end up sort of a muddy brown.
Gray. Yeah.
Maybe we'll get a little bit of that
turquoise surface stuff on it.
Let's find out.
[Music]
Wait, I actually love it.
It's so shiny.
[Music]
Guys, it's the beach.
We made the beach.
In the middle of the winter.
So the inside of these ornaments
are really pretty.
The outsides are just...
Mud.
Purplish sparkly mud, but mud.
That was really cool
with all the paint
like rushing into the globe.
Not, not much.
We got a few gold swirls,
but the color is just..
It's just...
Kind of all mixes.
We'll be selling these?
$400 as is appropriate and fair.
All right.
So this is kind of gorgeous.
Now that we know that--
Those are some
really cool swirls.
That is beautiful.
But it's freezing.
I want to heat it up.
I wanna boil it.
All right, that's lit,
but it's on fairly low heat.
I'm hoping we can
actually get to a point
where we can see this bubbling.
I think it's very likely
that it will light on fire.
But I do want to see
if we can get like a bubbling,
rolling boil before that.
Because I think it
will look interesting.
There's water running
down the outside of the pot,
because it got so cold.
It's actually frozen.
That it was frozen all
the way around, and now,
we're starting to thaw it,
and we've got just a few drips
down here at the bottom.
We sprayed in maybe 3/4
of an inch of paint
before we had to stop
for the day,
and we came back,
and I think that paint
got a lot colder.
It was still liquid,
but I'm guessing,
it didn't really mix very well.
And now, as it's heating up,
we've got some of that
raising up to the top.
When we stopped that yesterday,
it was a very green mix.
So it's bubbling,
but there's no heat
radiating off of it.
The side of it's cool.
That is slightly cool,
is I would say.
How-- the bubbles are weirding me out.
Now, my entire hand
is submerged in spray paint,
which is odd.
But awesome.
Very thin, and
it's like slippery,
so it kind of feels
like my hand is in oil.
So it's thinner than regular,
like house paint.
Definitely thinner
than house paint.
And yet, it's almost soapy.
It's interesting.
You can see as he's...
The the teal is coming through.
That was the teal that,
that we've sprayed
in the very beginning yesterday.
I am rubbing some of the paint
off of the bottom of the pot,
and it's definitely warmer.
As long as I keep
my fingers moving,
it's not like burning
them at all or anything.
[Music]
I think the solvents
in the paint are slightly
dissolving my glove.
They are.
That gloves
normally form-fitting.
[Music]
Well, that's a very very
thin bottom steel pot.
And so,
individual tiny little bits
of paint probably are boiling.
[Music]
Now, it's on high heat.
So now we're backing up.
Oh, and that is bubbling
much more vigorously.
[Music]
That could have been
potentially disastrous.
That is a lot
of flammable liquid.
We decided we had too
much flammable liquid
to just let that go,
and possibly light on fire.
Almost certainly light on fire.
And so, what we're going to do
instead is we're just going
to take it off of the burner,
move the propane tank far away,
and then see if we can light
the surface of the paint.
Because I really do think
it will light on fire,
but then, we have to deal
with it being on fire,
and we have a fire extinguisher,
which would probably put it out.
But it also sprays out
with a lot of force,
and maybe that would like
send burning paint flying.
The fumes from--
There's just so many things
that we think we might not want
to deal with right now,
especially if it's all that fire
surrounding a propane tank.
We're still gonna light it up.
We're going to see if I
can like the surface on fire.
But without the
propane tank there,
and then, just try putting
a board over to put it out,
and if that doesn't work,
then the fire extinguisher.
[Music]
Poke it with a stick.
I'm going to poke
it with a stick.
A flaming stick.
Yeah.
There we go.
[Music]
I don't think it like that.
No.
[Music]
That's got to be
the most extreme way
to graffiti anything ever.
[Music]
Dries really fast.
That's a lot of boiled paint.
[Music]
Well, I think we
should take this paint,
just set it somewhere.
Just leave it?
For like six months,
and see if it dries out.
Let's do it.
Stay tuned for six months,
and maybe we'll show
you the dried out paint.
That's not going
to be in this video,
because we're not
waiting six months.
Guys, that's it for today.
Come back in maybe six months,
and we'll show you
what's happened to this pot
of spray paint.
As for now, you know,
we've always got more
for you to see.
That box of the top is going
to take you to our last video.
You should go check that out.
The other box
is going to show you
what YouTube thinks you
should be watching next.
And if you aren't subscribed
to our Channel,
hit this bomb to join the club.
That way, you'll never miss
out on a cool video.
Don't forget to ring that bell,
and we'll see you
in the next one.
Talk to you then.